dimanche 22 mars ce sera le premier tour
des élections départementales nous en
parlons sur notre antenne et comme
chaque soir on ouvre notre journal de
campagne
bonsoir ligne anglais ont fait le tour
des cantons en bourgogne avec ce soir un
gros plan sur joigny oui le scénario
politique de ce canton se caractérise
par une primaire à droite udi contre
l'ump
une division qui correspond en fait à
deux réalités locales et départementales
localement la droite est divisée depuis
la fin du long règne de philippe
auberger et au niveau départemental une
partie de l'ump n'a pas pardonné à lui d
y rendre et villiers de leur avoir pris
la présidence du coup le ps espère en
profiter pour asseoir son ancrage dans
le centre de l'yonne dans ce canton qui
réunit vous le voyez en partie les
anciens canton de joigny et de
saint-julien-du-sault nathalie baffert
et christian mirabeau quelle que soit
l'issue du scrutin cette élection est
d'ores et déjà placé sous le signe du
renouveau
aucun des deux sortants de droite ne se
représente
ce qui ne change pas en revanche à
joigny ce sont les divisions à droite
pas fonder cette fois ci sur des
querelles de personnes mais bel et bien
sur le fond il ya des propos qui me
convient pas qu'ils sont un peu plus du
côté
trop droite voilà et donc ça s'est passé
c'est impossible pour moi je me sens pas
totalement par tout ce qui représente il
ya des choses que avec lesquels je ne
suis pas du tout en accord
donc je me voyais pas être quelqu'un
investi par m déjà c'est pas une droite
divisée ces deux partis qui ne sont pas
de droite
les deux ne sont pas à droite et on a lu
dei qui est plutôt de tendance au centre
et l'ump aujourd'hui dans le canton
on a clairement lui des élus ump bourse
est une division de la droite et du
centre
mais moi je ne considère pas ça comme
une division de la droite vous voilà qui
potentiellement pourrait faire les
affaires de la gauche le ps bien
implanté désormais à joigny a été
confortablement réélu aux dernières
municipales
le candidat socialiste président de la
communauté de communes du jovinien qui
couvrent peu ou prou les limites du
nouveau canton est le seul de tous les
postulants qui peut compter sur une
certaine notoriété
pour ma part ça fait sept ans que je
suis président de la communauté de
communes sept ans que je vois l'ensemble
des mères chaque semaine je pense que je
connais par coeur sur le bout des doigts
les dossiers de ce canton les besoins
des communes des villes des deux villes
du canton mais aussi des villages la
différence c'est que moi ça fait j'ai
déjà engagé des choses j'ai déjà engagé
les choses
mais les divisions idéologiques fracture
également la gauche avec un binôme verts
front de gauche qui fait bloc face au ps
je ne parlerai pas de division puisqu'il
ya la gauche du front de gauche la
gauche que les verts ont intégré et la
gauche l'ancienne gauche qu'on pourrait
appeler du ps la politique ultra
libérale du ps ne peut pas être
considéré à gauche donc à partir non on
ne peut pas la considérer à gauche je
vois pas où est la division
bonjour monsieur est-ce que vous
intéresser aux élections départementales
reste une inconnue comme partout le
score du front national
l'ambition frontiste est ici porté par
un inconnu justement puisqu'il réside
dans le sud de l'yonne et il mise sur
les fondamentaux du parti
ces documents pour alimenter votre
réflexion on voit qu'il ya un effort qui
est consenti sur le quartier de la
madeleine qui concentre une population
étrangère importante et les français je
vis mien historiquement s'interroge en
dix ans et nous que se passe-t-il donc
aujourd'hui il s'agit de rétablir une
justice sociale en faveur des français
qui ont toujours habité ici
reste à savoir si ce sont les enjeux
nationaux ou réellement locaux qui vont
guider les électeurs la gauche pourrait
pâtir d'un vote sanction
pendant que la droite dans ce coin de
l'yonne n'en finit plus de se déchirer
alors après le gros plan sur un canton
et un autre incontournable dans ce
journal c'est la campagne vu des réseaux
sociaux
oui pas beaucoup de polémique
aujourd'hui mais de l'humain surtout
alors que certains réfléchissent à
rendre le vote obligatoire
le candidat udi de torigni dans l'yonne
alexandre bouchier partagent un dessin
qui rappelle que le droit de vote
beaucoup en rêvent ailleurs dans le
monde
pendant que certains s'en désintéressent
chez nous dans l'yonne encore gilles
pirman conseillers sortants de droite
attaqué par d'autres candidats ump dans
le canton de sens un défend son bilan
avec une phrase de victor hugo mois qui
pourrait mordre je ris une attitude rare
dans une campagne où on mord pas mal
tout de même
et puis une campagne électorale ça peut
être agréable aussi quand il fait beau
que le printemps arrive regarder elle
est pas belle l'équipe de guillaume
weecksteen candidats de gauche à 105
grand spécialiste du cmfi mignon il n'y
a pas que la politique dans la vie il ya
aussi le foot
ah ouais chelsea paris saint germain
hier soir pas la soirée idéale pour
programmer un minimum
union comme l'avouent thierry corniot
candidats à saint-florentin voilà vous
voyez son tweet ce matin et puis un
autre élu un grand passionné de football
arnaud danjean député européen
manifestement pas fan habituellement de
la coiffure du brésilien david luiz mais
qui lui a tout pardonné
hier soir après son but et pendant ce
temps là certains voient plus loin et
pense déjà à d'autres élections les
régionales et oui prévu en décembre pour
la bourgogne franche comté avec l'
annonce sur twitter aujourd'hui d'un
sondage à paraître dans le figaro
magazine qui donne à droite un net
avantage à alain joyan des sur françois
sauvadet
dans l'hypothèse où ils seraient tous
les deux candidats une information
relayée toute la journée vous vous en
doutez par les proches d'anna joyan b
rajoutons que ce soit aux mages place le
front national à 26% en tête et le ps à
20%
rajoutons aussi que c'est un sondage
étonnamment précoce alors que le
bourguignon françois sauvadet n'a pas
annoncé sa candidature et que la
bourgogne et la plus grande région des
deux merci beaucoup lignon et nous
retrouverons eric sicaud demain pour une
nouvelle page politique